Speaker 1: More very bad news for the failed
former president. And and there will be other
bad news for him today as well. Donald Trump
was deposed today. This is major, major news
and we already have some reports as to what took
place. Trump to be deposed Wednesday morning
in New York. Attorney general's probe of his
business. This is something Trump has been seeking
to avoid for a very long time. Donald Trump's
deposition for New York's inquiry into the Trump
organization is set for Wednesday. Trump is set to
be grilled in Manhattan by lawyers from New York's
attorney general, Letitia James. James has accused
Trump of misstating property values to win tax
breaks and bank loans. Remember the way that that
works? You have a property. Trump has a building.
Let's say it's worth $2 million. When Trump wants
to use that building as collateral for a loan,
he says this is a $3 million building. And then
when Trump wants to have a lower tax liability in
property taxes on the building, he says it's only
worth $1 million. That is at the nexus at the core
of this investigation. The article says Donald
Trump is scheduled to sit for his long delayed
court ordered deposition Wednesday morning. We
already have a report about how it went. Donald
Trump claiming that he refused to answer any
questions from the attorney general. CNBC Report
Trump says he refused to answer New York Attorney
General's questions in probe of his business.
Trump made the announcement shortly after he
arrived at the offices of AG Letitia James. I once
asked, if you're innocent, why are you taking the
Fifth Amendment? Now I know the answer to that
question. Remember, Trump used to say, only the
mob takes the Fifth. Why take the Fifth if you're
innocent? And now Donald Trump availing himself
of his Fifth Amendment right, which he reportedly
invoked numerous times today. Donald Trump also
commenting on truth social. In advance of the
hearing, quote, In New York City tonight, seeing
racist New York state attorney general tomorrow
for a continuation of the greatest witch hunt
in U.S. history. My great company and myself are
being attacked from all sides. Banana Republic.
No, sir. I'm coming to you with tears in my eyes
and saying, No, sir. Potentially accountability
for anyone because no one is above the law in
the United States is a good thing. In fact, many
so-called banana republic sort of a pejorative
Trump might sometimes call them asshole countries.
One of the hallmarks of many of those countries is
there is not accountability for those in the top
echelons of power and privilege. If there is such
accountability in the United States, that would
be a good thing, not a bad thing. So, so much bad
news for Donald Trump after the break. Trump is
frenetically seeking a criminal defense attorney
and Donald Trump's taxes are going to be
given to the House of Representatives.
Could this be the worst 72 hour period for
Trump that we can remember? Let me know your
thoughts. Find me on Twitter at the Pacman
and we'll continue after this short break